I'm assistant
engineering and affiliated
certain engineering public policy I
teach electric power systems and
undergraduate course teaching the
fundamental tools and in in spring
semester I teach the graduate level
course optimization in energy networks
so I'm mostly focusing on the optimal
operation of the electric power system
looking at how do we coordinate best
different elements in the system such as
generation load storage devices and so
on so in the past we had mostly large
power plants which were producing the
electric energy and then it was
transmitted to the loads and the loads
were just fixed we supplied them as as
needed but now moving towards
distributed generation having hopefully
having more storage in the system and
flexible loads meaning that you might be
able to tell the utility ok you can
adjust my thermostat such that you're
becoming a flexible which they can
adjust most of my work focuses on
developing methods and algorithms to
optimally use elements that we have in
the system so what I'm basically trying
to do is let's say you have a storage
device but the storage device itself
doesn't help you much yet you need to
know when to charge when to discharge
storage device and so on so I'm
providing the method to get the most out
of that storage device the goal of my
work is basically to minimize the cost
by optimally using the existing
components that we have in the system as
well as integrating new technology has
make optimal use of these technologies
especially in the viewpoint when we
think about well we want to move towards
a renewable energy future and often the
counter-argument towards that as well
it's so much more expensive and so on so
especially in in this situation it's
it's highly critical that you're making
on yourself of what you what he have in
the system